their own secretary swella bravaman has
admitted that she sent official
documents to her personal email address
on six occasions the security breaches
led to her resignation before she was
then reappointed to the same role by
Rishi sunak less than a week later while
swella bravman gave the explanation in a
letter to the chair of the home Affairs
Select Committee in which she again
apologizes for her mistakes well let's
take you through the timeline of events
that the Home Secretary has outlined in
her letter
at 7 25 on October 19th the Home
Secretary says she used her personal
email account on her personal phone
email
to draft a document to Sir John Hayes a
former security minister just before
nine o'clock she arrived at the home
office and went straight into
back-to-back meetings with officials
around 10 o'clock that day the Home
Secretary received a reply to her email
from a parliamentary employee saying
this has been sent to me an error
two minutes past 10 she then replied to
the Parliamentary employees saying
please delete the message and ignore
thanks before then going straight into a
home office departmental board meeting
11 20. the Home Secretary went to the
House of Commons to meet with
constituents in central Lobby and
finally while she was there in central
Lobby 11 50 and by coincidence she saw
the chief whip Andrew Percy the chief
whip asked her to speak to Mr Percy and
he told her that her email had been
received by a member of his
parliamentary staff and he was concerned
about her having sent the email to Sir
John and to his staff member well let's
bring in our political correspondent Ali
Fortescue Ali it's quite a lot of times
to be resending official documentation
to yourself by email isn't it
yes it is I think there are two um
issues that are raised from this email I
mean there's been plenty of calls
including from santori MPS for their
Home Secretary to give Clarity to be
transparent about what exactly happened
and solely over the course of the
weekend we were starting to piece
together a timeline of events and this
letter does sort of confirm the timeline
that we thought as you were saying that
this happened at about
um 7 30 that she realized what happened
at about 10 o'clock and that she by
coincidence as she says
um saw the chief whip at about 1150 and
it was after that that she raised this
issue with the cabinet office so we for
the first time have a bit of clarity on
what was happening during that time and
there have been calls for clarity but I
I suspect that perhaps this will
certainly with the labor party will
raise more questions as well because as
you were reading there the reasons why
she didn't raise the issue for example
there's issues meeting two constituents
that she had a home office meeting I
think labor will say that that actually
that that is not enough for her to not
raise what was a security breach
information that she'd shared by
accident with someone on her personal
phone and that there is no reason why it
should have taken a number of hours the
other issue is that she said in her
resignation letter that she raised the
issue a rapidly reported this on
official channels is what she said but
we can see here from her timeline of
events that it was only after she by
coincidence as she put it saw the chief
whip that she then raised it with the
cabinet office so was this would she
have raised it anyway was this because
she was in meetings that's what she said
but I think that timeline will raise
alarm bells for some and I think the
other thing as you rightly mentioned is
the fact that this has happened on 6
um occasions that she forwarded
government documents um to her personal
email so not just one time that she
forwarded documents but on six different
occasions which clearly
um is significant and I think that is
something
um that will be seized on and I think
there are those who think that this is
something that reflects not just badly
on the Home Secretary but badly on the
Prime Minister on his judgment labor of
course say that it was a grubby deal
um kirst armor last week at Prime
Minister's questions seizing on the
issue of swella bravement as to why she
was appointed as Home Secretary the
Prime Minister says that he's reaching
all different wings of the party
bringing together the talents of the
conservative party he knows that he
needs to heal a deeply divided party and
sweater braveman is someone that has had
sway on the right of the party he says
that she she made a mistake and she's
apologized for that but clearly a week
into his Premiership the the controversy
surrounding his Home Secretary isn't
going anywhere and clearly has come as a
political cost to the Prime Minister and
I think this letter as I say is the
first time we've seen Clarity on some of
the events around what happened on that
day that she resigned but does raise
further questions as well that she will
have to answer